♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS)
REPORTER:
We're now joined by Kendall Roy.
Why did you get involved?
Why did you back out?
I saw their plan
and my dad's plan was better.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the first fucking thing
my son's ever done right
in his life.
LOGAN ROY: We need to
discuss this bear hug.
Stick or sell?
I think you should fight.
You're the one who built it all.
LOGAN:
Kendall and Roman will act
as co-chief operating officers.
He tried to help
your oldest enemy to take over
and he gets the promotion?
I'd like to ask you to come in
and be the next chief executive
of this company.
I'm still applying for the job
of
President of the United States.
Do you think that's
a natural progression,
from never done nothing never
to the most important job
in the world?
We're going for PGM.
We leverage up and eat Pierce,
we're too big for Sandy
and Stewey to come for.
NAN PIERCE:
Welcome to Tern Haven,
our city on a hill.
I have to ask.
Any thought given
to whom you might
hand over the keys?
Just tell 'em it's gonna be me.
Fuck off.
REPORTER 2:
We had a tip-off some time ago.
GERRI KELLMAN:
New York Magazine working
on a substantial piece.
Data wipes, NDAs,
cruise malpractice.
GREG HIRSCH: So,
you know when you had me destroy
those documents at Cruises?
I kept a few.
(LAUGHING) Where are they,
those papers?
-I'll never tell.
-(HYSTERICAL LAUGHTER)
GERRI: A shareholder vote
is going to be close.
Could you seduce...?
Should we get married?
That's not equivalent.
You'll have to think about it.
I get it. So, let it...
SENATOR GIL EAVIS: What
did you know about wrongdoing
by means of
the keeping of shadow logs?
I believe my son was
across that operation.
SIOBHAN ROY:
You think we're through?
Not with the shareholders.
Time for a blood sacrifice.
So, whose big hairy foot's
gonna fit in the glass slipper?
-Tom looks logical.
-What?!
I have to be an honest broker.
I'm really pretty unhappy being
with you.
KENDALL ROY: I like her, dad.
I just don't want you fucked
on drugs and she's part of it.
You're a cross to clean up.
The optics make sense.
And now, you're the face.
You're not a killer.
You have to be a killer.
I have an announcement to make
about wrongdoing
at Waystar Royco.
The truth is,
that my father
is a malignant presence,
a bully, and a liar.
And this is the day
his reign ends.